diese stinkende abfall berge sind die
endstation von deutschlands plastikmüll
statt wie versprochen recycelt oder zu
strom verwandelt zu werden
landet der von uns sorgfältig sortiert
der erste welt abfall am anderen ende
des globus im dschungel von malaysia
mindestens 30 prozent des plastikmülls
kann nicht recycelt werden
es ist zu viel müll für die großen
verbrennungsanlagen die
luftverschmutzung und der gestank
während zu schlimm
deshalb werden kleinere mengen einfach
wild verbrannt oder der müll wird
irgendwo hingeworfen
wir haben nachts den rauch gerochen
wusste nicht woher er kam meine cousine
hat mir dann erzählt dass hier eine
fabrik in der nähe ist man hört die
maschinen laufen hier wird gearbeitet
das ist eine der illegalen müll
verarbeitungs fabriken in der gegend die
meisten illegalen fabrikanten sind die
strafen der regierung egal da guckt
jemand lass uns abhauen
[Musik]